we protect the bay all cost Sony what I
don't know what this means
so we're bringing in drugs to the bay
we're not cops
we're lifeguards we got a little recon
to do so in treating this place you can
help train whatever it is it feels
amazing you got to get some hard
evidence need you to check for needle
marks no God tell me Steve Oh Oh Mikey
okay
get closer oh there is a hole that's his
bundle it's supposed to that say watch
[Music]
[Music]
our team is the heart soul of this very
Beach protect a bay at all cost
Oh what I don't know what this
we want the Reese's talking about you
guys this is McSorley the new owner of
the hunger club I know the club's
probably not your scene but you're
standing in the future all the bad [ __ ]
happening in our Beach started once she
took over and my balls say we need to go
over there and check it out I've all day
thinking he's right that's true what a
[ __ ] your ball sound like three year old
girls I don't know man what's about a
talk but they're wise my time we got
going to cover like knit yeah
undercover yeah little do undercover you
think I'm a drug dealer
honey look at me oh don't even start my
card take care of them already
why are we in the morgue what come and
put her down Ali hi Barry doctors are
empty why'd you pick that Roy Thomas
it's just a little dead man's fat
nothing a baby
you
you